hello guys my name is a Turner and
welcome to a video about love and death
32 so first of all what is Laden dead
for those of you who do not know a lot
um dare or ludum dare a if you want to
be all fancy is a 48-hour game
programming competition primarily it's
actually divided into two things I'll
get to that but basically you have 48
hours to make a game from scratch so all
assets and whatnot can be kept they have
to be created within those 48 hours
however you can use existing code and
engines and stuff like that again we'll
get to that the point is you have 48
hours to make a game from scratch right
pretty cool so i usually do these things
this is actually going to be my seventh
1 i'm making this video because lot i'm
dare 32 so 30 second competition starts
tomorrow ok which is about probably
around 24 no sorry 12 hours from when
this video goes out around that right
and yeah and i'll be doing it so what
that means is i'll be live streaming for
the entire weekend ok so if you want to
watch me make a game from scratch in 48
hours well you'd better you'd better
visit that live stream there's also
another another section of blood and air
which is called a jam basically you have
72 hours you can work in teams year and
have to release your source code and
there's a few different things like that
and you can use pre-made assets and
pretty sure all that stuff but i will be
doing the competition as as usual which
means i'll be working by myself and i'll
be basically writing the entire game
within those 48 hours so the biggest
question I get is when will you be
streaming and generally all of that
stuff so what I've done is I've set up a
new website called livejournal com now
live with the trainer com will have a
countdown timer to when I'm next
streaming okay so for example at the
time of me recording this livejournal
com says that next stream is in 15 hours
43 minutes and 15 seconds so it's a
legitimate just countdown timer to when
i'll be streaming so you can convert
that into your time zone you can just
count on your hand how many hours left
until cherno will start streaming all
that stuff so I've met real easy and as
a bonus when I do start streaming live
the trainer
will transform into an embedded stream
if you don't want to watch on Twitch for
some reason but you can always watch it
on twitch its twitch.tv for such the
channel or live doctor channel com so
that's all the live streaming stuff out
of the way that's how that's going to
happen so hopefully I'll see a lot of
you guys there because as usual these
things are usually a lot of fun so it
should be great and again the theme for
the competition gets released when it
starts which is for me 11am australian
eastern standard time on saturday the
18th of april 2015 but um the theme will
get all these when it starts so i don't
know what kind of gown gonna make but
let's go over a few of the things i'll
be using okay so i will be using my
Sparky game engine which i've been
working on for the past like I think six
weeks ish I'm guessing I'm pulling a
number out of my head I don't know but
um this pocket game engine so the entire
like series of how I made that game
engine can actually be found here on
YouTube as you've probably noticed
because I've been uploading quiet quite
a lot of videos recently so if you want
to see that engine being created from
scratch you can actually just you can
actually just go to video one or the
intro video or whatever there's a
playlist i'll link the playlist below as
well and yeah and you can literally just
you can literally just watch the entire
creation of that and it's quite fun
because all of that was live-streamed as
well so that's the case if you want to
learn how the game engine was made and
all and all not not just how it was made
but all the processes that went into
creative that game engine because all of
it was live-streamed even the failures
and all that stuff the other thing i
wanted to mention is that game engine is
open source it's under the apache to
license which basically the only
restriction without licenses the fact
that if you do use sparky for your own
damage and you have to be like i used
the Sparky engine created by Turner
right you can't be like yeah this is my
own engine basically right which is I
think it's fair so you have to attribute
me basically that's it though like it's
pretty much permissive you can use it
for commercial projects if you like and
whatnot you can use for anything you
want you don't have to open source your
project so it's not like the GPL license
but yes I feel free to use
Sparky it's very very raw it's not
exactly finished yet and it only
supports 2d right now so that means i
will probably in fact i will be making a
2-d game for a lot and dad this time
around which is fine i don't think well
again that's not really going to matter
too much you'll find that it will do i
don't think it'll subtract at all
because i can still do a lot of pretty
crazy things with 2d to make it look
really quiet 3d but anyway the point is
technically from that kind of
perspective it is a 2d engine right now
also with it as i mentioned it is quite
raw it is there are a few things that
probably need to be fixed and improved
because again I've only spent about it's
been about six weeks working on it so i
will be modifying the end and i imagine
quite a bit but the bonus thing is the
game will be available for windows as
well as on the internet so you will be
able to play this game inside your
browser even though was written in
Sparky so the the other thing I should
mention is the language i'll be using
this time around is c plus plus okay
I've never used see past bolt's before
for love and death just because it takes
a bit too long but I've got this game
engine now I'm pretty confident that
since that's out of the way and I don't
have to make a game engine basically I
can just you know I can take the hit of
having to spend slightly longer
developing the game in C++ okay but that
C++ will actually be compiled through
Sparky and & M scripting to run inside a
web browser so that's good because it
lets me kind of program on desktop and
then export the web kind of like what
unity doesn't want more which i think is
a very good first step in making Sparky
but better lot and air engine anyway
that's the plan so it's going to be a
lot of fun i'll be streaming the whole
time one question i want to leave you
guys with though before I go and
remember livejournal com if you want to
get stream updates and why not the the
final question I want to leave you guys
with is should I have a face cam in the
stream for the entire duration of it
because i don't know i was thinking
about this the face cam is a bit it
obstructs quite a bit of the video it
also kind of I don't know it it's not
it's it's a bit more it's a bit more of
a pain to set up and whatnot and it's
just it is it is
slight hassle but on the other hand it
makes the I I think it makes it much
more interesting and the fact that you
can kind of see my emotions and one on
and so just minutes of silence when I'm
thinking about something so it might be
better in that regard I don't know I'm
actually leaving it completely up to you
guys so if you want a facecam leave a
comment below if you don't I just leave
a comment being like I don't want a face
cam ok and I will do whatever you guys
decide so that's the plan anyway
twitch.tv for such the cherno or
livejournal com starts tomorrow and I
will see you guys there goodbye